got a special edition of talk on the
table we're joined by our friends that's
Drew Barrymore and host of the what's
the name of your show oh it's the Drew
Barrymore show I like co-host I know
Ross Matthews took a long time to get
that title yeah we're back together to
bring you some of the stories that we're
called Talk of the table and Drew you're
in Pole Position all right well my talk
of the table is about the key to
happiness according to Harvard
researchers the Harvard study of adult
development has tracked the lives of
hundreds of people for more than 80
years they say it's one of the longest
studies and it's still counting but to
find out what really leads to a happy
and fulfilling life apparently it all
boils down to one thing good
relationships the study found the
strength of a person's connections with
others can predict the health of both
their body and their brains as they go
through life because good relationship
acts as stress relievers and something
to live for in my opinion the
researchers recommend people look after
their social Fitness or tend to the
relationships just like they take care
of their physical fitness the current
lead researchers wrote a book with more
lessons from the study called the good
life and it's published by Simon
Schuster which is an imprint of
Paramount Global which owns CBS I can't
wait for this book don't we think this
is true yeah very true I don't need a
study for this I know that this is yeah
whether it's because your partner or
your best friend or whoever those
relationship you curate and brings
happiness because I say Rossi we're all
going to be trivia questions one day
what was the name of that black girl
that did
what was the name of that singer
so-and-so still alive but when you have
good relationships and good family
Foundation nothing you're never a trivia
question you do need a reminder actually
because people don't pick up the phone
and make that call and stay connected to
people that matter to them so let this
be a reminder you have to cultivate your
garden absolutely yes all right well my
talk at the table is the science behind
shower thoughts have you ever wondered
why you get your best ideas in the
shower you guys anyway yeah totally well
now research
you're not one of those people who get
the ideas there I've never wondered
about it oh you've never wondered you
said have you ever you know it happened
Fair Point yes the effect is right it
does happen it turns out it's scientific
researchers use the term the shower
effect to explain how completely
completing a moderately engaging
physical task like taking a shower can
promote creativity because it allows
your mind to wander and the ideal
moderate engaging activity is something
physical that takes some of your
attention but not all of it right but it
also can't be boring so that you don't
want to do it researchers suggest that
the shower effect can also happen like
while taking a walk or whatever I don't
know I'm a little too busy in the shower
luffying and doing a tour de force
performance yeah I mean I'm like I'm all
of Destiny's Child in the shower the key
thing you can't bring your phone in the
shower right that's it
oh really what do you got a little
Ziploc baggie in there I end up I have
to be careful I don't waste water
because I do a lot of thinking in the
shower really yeah this study speaks to
me Ross has left us with a great image
loofing and everything yeah oh my gosh
everybody picture it right now
Tony D all right my talk on the table uh
is uh some news out of AMC Theaters they
are testing a new pricing policy that
could affect all moviegoers eventually
this could be National it's an idea to
pay to charge more or less for different
tickets depending on where they are in
the theater so their standard sight line
value sight line and preferred sight
line preferred is that fat section in
the Middle where everyone tries to sit I
don't like this I don't like it but I
don't understand it I do get it they're
like look you pay this is what how it
works for Broadway this is how it works
for concerts so we're no different that
makes sense but that's different because
it's live entertainment to me also it's
live entertainment when you're in the
movie you're just all looking at the
same screen when you're sitting in a
theater it does matter where you sit
sometimes what's happening that's a good
point also I don't think it's fair to
charge us for something that we've never
been charged for before I always have a
problem yeah like when the airlines
started charging you for bags oh that
well don't get me started yeah I mean so
I I'm opposed what can we do about this
and I did E.T I know I know I'm like the
old
when I was in ET the tickets were two
dollars and fifty cents for a child and
450 for adults and you know I just think
that we have to look at the model of the
concession stand and the movie prices so
that families can go without stress and
concern on their Wallet not okay
Broadway come true about selling about
charging depending on where you sit you
think that's okay well you made such a
good argument about the live thing
because there are things in the
periphery whereas the screen you know I
don't know if this makes it more
attainable for people good I'd like to
see the same model used on the
concession stand yeah yeah you
definitely need to lower those costs or
just pop your popcorn at home I'm a good
boy I follow the rules but I'm a bad boy
at the movie theater right I will pop my
Jiffy Pop bring it with me really oh a
bag of popcorn I can imagine like your
own candy bar popcorn is Big popcorn I
didn't your man in person
just a cute little don't judge my man
first no
but this is a question about how we move
forward with movie theaters because I
think they're so important and I love
going with my kids and it's a sacred
place to be able to get lost in
storytelling and see yourself and get
you know I it just it's a it's a very
important sacred place to me but I don't
think the model Works compared to home
viewing and what that costs we've got to
make it a more even balance David we're
not going to lose a story you're going
to get your turn here we go my talk at
the table is a revealing vacation selfie
from Tom Brady oh my gosh I saw this oh
my God and more newly retired so he says
so Brady says he's keeping a promise
that he made last year to Recreation
good morning Brady brand underwear
campaign if it got more than 40 000
likes it did and so we got this third
strap photo which by the way if you're
going through for third straps this is
like an A plus well I feel good I feel
better knowing that he did it for a bet
though David for a bit yeah that he
wasn't just doing Tony the hand the
artfully draped your head I was like are
there outtakes that's something only a
man thinks about you know because I well
I'm just saying I didn't think of that
when I looked at the picture
I definitely did I'm sure it ran through
some mines
well I mean he's a great quarterback
turns out he's a great tight end as well
it's a large hand
I like Ross's reaction when the picture
came up oh my talking the table is a New
Yorker who thought that he was flying to
Australia Kingsley Burnett is his name
so he booked a trip to Sydney Australia
trying to find the cheapest flight got
on the plane and off he went the only
problem is this is what it looked like
when the plane landed snow on the ground
so where did he arrive he arrived in
Sydney Montana
fight to Sydney Montana not Sydney
Australia so Kenzie Burnett with his
friend new friend Carol Castellano who
works for American Airlines in Montana
she said I'll help you out he said the
thing was the airport codes they one
says Syd the other says sd-y so that can
Syd is Australia sdy is Montana He said
I did think it was a pretty good deal it
was taking off from LaGuardia that also
should have been a clue he says but in
Australia they said this is the second
time that this has happened but Sydney
handled it well he said Montana didn't
have kangaroos it had Carol so that was
good enough for me he's rescheduled his
trip to Australia in June okay but I was
like we need closure yes women love
closure I feel like we need to get him
to Australia do you remember the days
where you would get on the wrong flight
and then realize that at the last minute
and run off the plane I feel like that
never happens anymore is that just me
yes
[Laughter]
I'm always flying and I feel like in the
80s and 90s you would just get on the
wrong flight and they'd be like all
right well Drew were you in the
appropriate state
of mind
if you're Barrymore Ross Matthews thank
you both great thank you thank you